¡SXLorens! Ahí está Heavenly Donuts. Remodelado a tensionas de primera en inglés y en español. Heavenly Donuts en la SX, el mejor lugar para tomarte el mejor café.
En el 225 de la calle es Excelores. Hay un lugar único en su clase. Aroma Espa.
[REVISAR] En la Roma Spa.
De noche. La tienda de los artistas. La que te diste y te comunica, donde tú encuentras los mejores jeans. Camisas. Zapatos. Saquetes. Y chacabanas. Sé tú el artista y diste de te noche. La que pauta la moda al vestir. La primera. Además de noche es la única tienda que te fría cualquier teléfono iPhone o Galaxy sin importar tu crédito y con un mínimo de inicial de hasta 10 dólares
Y páginelo como puedas y cuando quiera. Regala un celular sin complicarte la vida. Ven a Denoche, donde está Miguel-o el presidente de la ESES. Denoche 49 SS Street 978 965 25 00
Escúchame, mujer. ¿Qué te gusta verte y sentirte bien? Ahora tienes un lugar para la limpieza facial, los masajes y la depilación corporal. Ese lugar es Marta's Asterix Center. Dos sesenta y ocho South Broadway en South Lawrence. Lo dures en llamar para una cita.
[REVISAR] Marcos.
¡All right! Clásicos de fin de semana. El espectáculo que tiene la radio en toda Nueva Inglaterra, hasta las seis de esta tarde. Te lleva clásicos...en su vida. A las cinco vengo como especial en boleros y vengo en boleros. Vengo así como romanticón para ser el sábado. Sí señor. Luego vino Moranaje con el bachatón
[REVISAR] La
Está preguntando si Guavo está abierto. No, no, no. Ya soy cuestión del año que viene. El primaso Franklin Checo está en Punta Cana y está escuchando y viendo también la transmisión de YouTube ahí en Punta Cana. Un abrazo de primo. Primo estoy hoy con este... ¿Cómo le ponemos? Esta estrella.
Este señor que le ha dado tanto al merengue y que la gente quizás no sabía que había arreglado tantos temas para el merengue precisamente. Estoy hablando de Sony Ovalles, y Sony también le arregló a los hermanos Rosario. Escuche.
Algo que acaba de destacar del maestro Sony Ovalles es que cuando llega la capital de la República allá en Santo Domingo, bueno pues formó parte de la banda de La Marina de Guerra. Cuando tenía solamente 17 años quería seguir avanzando en la música e entrar precisamente a
Al conservatorio nacional de música. Y para eso fue un poco difícil, al principio dice él y algo que él destaca es que cuando perteneció a la banda de la Marina de Guerra en ese tiempo estando ahí fue que asesinaron al presidente en ese entonces Rafael Leonida Trugillo. Recuerda porque justo en ese día él estaba en el hospital Marión
Ya que no se encontraba muy bien de salud y vio cuando entraron a Zacarias de la Cruz, el chufuero de Trujillo herido de 14 balazos esa noche. Las enfermeras y los doctores estaban histéricos pidiendo que nos mantuvieramos en silencio. ¡Wow! Qué periencia, eh? Esa imagina... qué momento. Clásicos de fin de semana es el espectáculo del radio en toda Nueva Inglaterra 95 1 FM 1400 AM. ¿Hasta las seis?
En el 49 de la calle S.C. Lawrence ahí está de noche, la tienda que te comunica, te viste y ahora también envía dinero a República Dominicana y tiene al internet wireless o sea inalámbrico que ya regresó y lo tienen devuelta en de noche. Hola buenas saludos. Herrera. Ese soy yo cuéntelo usted. Yo soy la tienda retelado. Ey hermano cuéntemelo
Estoy como el Don Plinche, que no cojo salsa. Dímelo, es Charlie. Tú sabes qué? Andaba acá... Conocí con un amigo tuyo ahí en Univision ¿Cómo se llama él? Richie Herrera. Camarografo, no, no el camarófono. Yo tengo varios amigos y voy a ver cómo va él. Te voy a decir al amigo. Él trabajó contigo ante la micro, me dijo.
En qué termas no, pero para saber. Pero ve acá, te voy a decir a mí mismo... El se llama... El se llama... Wehring, Wehring Cordero. Sí, sí, sí, sí, si, sí, sí. Una estrella ese.
Miro, miro. Creo que es el River Link creo. Sí está ahí en una visión Boston. Es señor. Richie, tú estabas diciendo algo de... de Sattrapa. Dígase Rafael de Unidos Tujillo. Sí señor. Y hay que recordar a la gente. Que hay allá...
Aparte de que hay hombres que son y fueron guapos, el doctor Dario Contreras en paz descanse. Este doctorazo que a su nombre lleva... En su memoria lleva el nombre del Dario Contreras, el traumatológico que está en la parte este de Santo Domingo. Él fue el que operó atrujillo de la próstota y los matones y los limpiasacos de trujillos le dijeron, ¡Doctor!
Y él se muere en esta operación. ¿Qué pasa? Dice, hay que enterrarlo mañana porque hieles y eso mueve el... Ay Dios mío! Ay Dios mío! ¡Ojajaja! Un abrazo, Richie. ¡Se cuesta! ¡Ay mamacita!
Que bueno, un abrazo. Es de los buenos. Tiene mucha historia también. Vamos a entrevistarlo en el escándalo. Se tiene muchas anécdotas. Estel viajaba como camarófoco con la mayoría de presidentes de la República Dominicana o viajó de las figuras políticas de la República Dominicana. Entonces ya usted sabe la historia que tiene ese señor. Bien!
Sony Ovalles arregla otro tema para los hermanos Rosario.
Y es solto que llore por ella.